[Music]
okay pat i'm going to ask you to explain
to us now the this idea of the hard
problem of consciousness because this
might be one of those questions that
brian's referring to so this was the
philosopher
david chalmers came up with this idea
for um asking why do we have phenomenal
experiences and you know can that be
answered by scientific inquiry do you
want to take us through this this idea
of this hard problem pat and what you
think on it
well it's a little hard for me to do
because um you know a problem that
somebody finds hard is a psychological
fact about them it's not a metaphysical
fact about the world
look go go back to my biology teacher he
found it hard to imagine how you could
get liviness itself out of dead
molecules
and thomas finds it hard to imagine how
you could get
phenomenal experiences out of physical
stuff
yeah okay it's hard to imagine there's a
lot of things that are hard to imagine
um
but
what kind of i mean what
amazing conclusion do you want to draw
from that what he wants to draw from
that is that consciousness is a
fundamental feature of the universe
along i mean he he would agree with
plonk
and i think well okay go for it then
but without data you're just another
person with an opinion and he's been
working on this now for 25 years or at
least he articulated it 25 years ago
there's been no progress on the problem
i mean if he really thinks it's a
fundamental feature of the universe
where are the experiments where are the
data where are the measurements
what's the program what's the plan there
is nothing and you know pan cyclists
climb out of the walls every sort of 80
years
and
and say wow you know everything is
conscious along with cow pies and fungus
and we're all supposed to go oh wow how
deep is that
and i'm kind of oh okay well
show me the data and i'm i'm i'm on
board
pat one thing let me ask you one
question though
again you've probably had more
conversations with david than i have
about this but i asked him about
that very point you know that there was
a time when
the onset of life seemed hard in that is
difficult
and couldn't it be that just as in that
case
50 100 years of scientific progress made
that problem not go away but kind of
evaporated in terms of it seeming so
complete mysterious his response to me
was when he uses the word hard he's not
using like a subjective sense that he
finds it hard he's saying this is a
unique problem because
the data is only first person accessible
so all the other problems of the world
are third-party accessible type problems
this one being fundamentally different
because it's only you and i as
individuals that can access our own
phenomenal experience unconscious
awareness
that's
what i understand him to have meant when
he said the word hard yeah i think i
think that he does but i mean look only
i have my digestion
you don't have my digestion
the waters doesn't have my oh it's so
mysterious my digestion right but but a
doctor you know
of the right variety can pretty much
gain access to the data of your
digestive system but it's pretty hard to
no you can't as in the propofol
experiment i described
the propofol experiments that emery
brown did is an instance where
we do have an understanding of what was
lost and why it was lost we didn't have
the experience itself but that's the
point but i think that's exactly the
point
i can know everything there is to know
about the nature of pregnancy
it won't make me pregnant there's a
different route to pregnancy
and similarly when he says you can know
everything there is to know about blue
but it won't cause you to see blue i
want
that's just like saying i should become
pregnant if i know everything there is
to know about pregnancy
i mean it's stale now i'm sorry but it's
just stale
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the institute of art
and ideas at iai tv